[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
the question is mrs. Norris a maledictis
we know mrs. Norris as the loyal feline
companion of Argus Filch Hogwarts
caretaker and resident squib Filch first
assumed the role of caretaker in 1968
succeeding apollyon Pringle and has been
roaming the halls of Hogwarts ever since
along with his trusty feline companion
mrs. Norris Filch is always on the
lookout for students breaking the rules
Filch is quite a misunderstood character
and he's really glossed over in the
films I'm not sure that it's even
addressed that he's a squib the film's
paint him in quite a negative light
almost as if he is evil but in reality
Filch is just bitter he was born a
non-magical man into a magical world
which I expect would be exceptionally
difficult and though he doesn't hate the
students he does love to give him a hard
time which I suppose we can just let him
have but if there's one thing that's for
certain
Filch loves his feline companion mrs.
norris who is the subject of this video
mrs. Norris is a female cat with dust
colored fur and piercing yellow eyes as
is common with the film adaptations mrs.
Norris's appearance is inconsistent with
the book in the early films she was
shown to have red eyes and in the later
films she had blue eyes
additionally the films portrayed her as
having brown and gray fur mrs. Norris's
name comes from a character in Jane
Austen's Mansfield Park and was borrowed
for the Harry Potter series by Rowling
there are actually some parallels
between the two mrs. Norris as well as
the mrs. Norris from Mansfield Park is
judgmental disagreeable and villainous
to an extent I'm sure the students of
Hogwarts look at mrs. Norris in a
similar light one thing that's worth
asking though is why would filter named
his cat mrs. Norris as his Jane Austen
fan fans think that this could perhaps
be a subtle hint at a relationship
between him and Hogwarts librarian
Madame pants who I'm sure would be
familiar with the works of Austen Madame
pants like Filch was not popular with
the student body either and well the two
would be perfect together back to filter
Norris the two are never apart except
for when they've temporarily decided to
scout out different areas of the school
they seem to have an almost quasi
telepathic connection as they are able
to communicate in spite of the fact that
they are just well squid and cat when
mrs. Norris encounter students
misbehaving village seems to show up
right away and vice versa
so what could the explanation be for
their complicated relationship and how
do they achieve near human levels of
interaction one theory for this is that
mrs. Norris Samara dictor's if
maledictis sounds familiar then you're
probably thinking of Nagini Voldemort's
trusty sidekick who also happens to be a
confirmed maledictis the term maledictis
refers to any woman
they are always women suffering from a
blood curse that causes them to
eventually and permanently transform
into a beast the curse persists for
generations and is passed down from one
generation to the next from mother to
daughter before permanently transforming
which inevitably happens to all of them
they have control over their
transformations and can transform back
and forth between a human and animal
forms much like an animagus however
eventually they lose this control and
are stuck in their animal form forever
in fantastic beasts New Guinea is still
shown in the earlier stages of her
gradual transformation and seems to be
able to switch between the two forms
relatively easily so why do we think
that mrs. Norris might be a maledictis
first off she's incredibly intelligent
and yes cats are intelligent but not to
the extent that mrs. Norris showcases in
the books and films one argument for
this is that mrs. Norris is part nasal
measles are magical creatures that
resemble cats have a very high level of
intelligence and are said to even have
an uncanny ability to detect suspicious
and distrustful people this would be a
perfect explanation for mrs. Norris
being
she is if JK Rowling hadn't already
entirely refuted that claim given it the
option of her being an easel is off the
table entirely the prospect of her being
a maledictis is looking more and more
likely next mrs. norris seems to be
unusually old for a housecat though we
don't know her exact age just got to be
well above average life expectancy after
all in chapter 10 of the Prisoner of
Azkaban Harry sees our very own mrs.
Norris on the marauders map the more
orders attend Hogwarts from 1971 to 1978
and if mrs. Norris was notable enough to
be included on their map it's likely
that she would have been giving them
trouble for at least a few years for
this reason I would expected the
Marauders dealt with mrs. Norris during
the first couple of years they attended
the school if this is the case even if
mrs. Norris was born the same exact year
that they started she would still be
twenty-seven years old by the time the
Battle of Hogwarts occurred in 1998
which we know that she participated in
she was seen hissing screeching and
batting at owls during the battle which
is rather sprightly behavior for such an
old cat furthermore this is a far reach
from the life expectancy of an average
house cat and this is all assuming that
she was born the exact year that they
started when in reality it was probably
before them in fact
Filch started at school in 68 and I'm
willing to bet that she started
alongside him in my opinion this
supports the claim that mrs. Norris is a
maledictis as a maledictis form is said
to not be limited by the lifespan of the
animal they transform into bearing all
of this in mind there's just no way that
mrs. Norris is a regular house cat if
she isn't part kneazle then there has
got to be some sort of other explanation
I was honestly a bit surprised enrolling
announced that mrs. Norris isn't an
easel as it would provide us with such a
clear answer that would address all of
the above points I would even argue that
mrs. Norris has exhibited intelligence
beyond that of an easel but I'm not sure
that I know enough about measles to so
boldly make that claim if we look at the
facts Miss
Norris is incredibly incredibly
intelligent and seems to exhibit the
behavior very young cat at an age that
is far out of reach except in very few
circumstances for the average house cat
various studies have stated the median
age for house cat is 14 which is nearly
half what mrs. Norris would have been
during the Battle of Hogwarts I don't
see how you could reasonably claim this
is just a regular cat unless the
duration of her life was somehow
extended through magic if we look at the
relationship between Voldemort and
Nagini it's very similar to the
relationship between Filch and mrs.
Norris
when Nagini first discovered Voldemort
she was just a lost maledictis devoid of
communication and when she finally found
him she leapt at the opportunity to be
with someone who could finally
understand her someone who she could
finally tell her story to furthermore
while Nagini was maybe not so similar to
Voldemort initially she developed over
time and became more and more like her
human companion
something that I can totally imagine
happening with mrs. Norris and Filch who
are so seemingly alike one issue with
this comparison however is that
Voldemort can speak Parseltongue meaning
that he's able to communicate with
snakes and Filch is just a squid can
squid speak cat in 1992 when mrs. Norris
was petrified by Salazar Slytherin's
basilisk Filch first blamed harry potter
who was spotted right at the scene of
the crime
Filch is visibly more upset than we've
ever seen him before and says in front
of everyone you killed my cat I'll kill
you I'll tell you while Filch's bitter
and a bit hard to deal with sometimes
he's not usually so violent in nature
and this passion that he's exhibiting to
me suggests that perhaps he knows mrs.
Norris on a deeper level perhaps he
knows something about her that the rest
of us don't
if mrs. Norris is a maledictis then we
can only assume that Filch knows her on
a much deeper level than anyone else and
this would explain their bond it would
also explain partly while Filch is as
bitter as he is having lost someone that
he truly cared for in part due to a
blood curse but who could she be a
former love interest a relative who
knows losing a loved one to magic
and being born a squib I can see why he
is the way that he is compelling
arguments right here's where it gets
less interesting there have been long
circulating rumors that mrs. Norris is
an unregistered and a Magus and in an
interview in 2005 Rowling responded to
the rumors with the following no she's
just an intelligent and unpleasant cat
if you're anything like me then you're
probably going to be dissatisfied with
this answer if mrs. Norris is just an
intelligent cat how does she have a
quasi telepathic relationship with Filch
how is she bouncing off the walls
hissing and swatting at owls at 27 years
of age it just doesn't add up and I'd
like to see a new answer out of Rowling
particularly as it's been quite a bit of
time since her old response and the term
maledictis was rarely discussed until
more recent years Rowling has a bit of a
history of saying things that she
doesn't necessarily mean as well as
things that don't necessarily make sense
so I'm interested to see if she ends up
revising her original statement what do
you guys think
are you also unconvinced that mrs.
norris is just a regular house cat how
old do you think she actually is let me
know in the comment section below until
next time you're a wizard Harry